[音楽]
th
外国人に話しかけられた気で英語で困ってしまったことありませんか
困ってる外国人助けてあげられるくらい話せるようになりたいですよね
今日は6分間で私のをバイリンガルになれちゃうレッスンを提供させていただきます
英語が全くできないところから版として英会話主任講師になり
25年間同時通訳者として県菅首相
前安倍首相国連事務総長などの同時通訳を務めてきました
でーも
1万回日本と世界の愛とあらゆる分野の通訳をしながら
学校で教えている正しい英語を話していたのはたった1割なんです
ダライラマも実際 ob もヘアぴゅあふぁー線
俺中学期末試験だったら罰ですよ
でも世界中が感動してるんです
人に伝えるのに正しい英語はいらないんです
でも
正しい英語を勉強していても伝わらないこともあったんです
東いくでほぼ満点の私実際
外国人の上司に帰国子女の彼女の toeic 全然君はに低いけど彼女の英語の方が
ぜんぜんわかりやすいんだよね
怒られました
英検1級とっても映画が笑えません
英検1級の単語等いくの幹部に使ったらそんな単語知らないよーって言われました
何かが足りないそう思って作った英会話の今日は勉強法を紹介させていただきます
でも実は
バイリンガルになるってそんなに難しいことじゃないんです
たった一つ
応答のイメージ入れるだけでいいんです
そして手に入れたバイリンガルのはなんとあなたの脳の中のたーーーくさんの部位を
使ってくれることで発想がどんどん豊かになってそしてなんと
認知症の発症も遅らせてくれるんです
これ高齢化社会の日本に朗報ですよ
ということで早速レスをスタートしていきたいとおもいます
では流博すしてどうぞを聞いてください
seasar 2分スタートフィニッシュ n 3目立つ
全然わからなかったひと安心してくださいこれから魔法をかけていきますよ
ではまず日本語で意味を理解しましょうう大きい声でこちらを一発で脳に入れると思い
ながら音読してくださいいきますよせーのこれからたった3分の間に社会的な運動が
起きる様子をご覧いただきたいと思いますと彼は言っていたんです
意味わかりましたねでは今度は auto
のイメージを弟意味を一致させながらインストールしていきますよ私の後に真似ながら
言ってくださいいきますよ
そうは
ウォッチむめ
8分
スタート9分ですいい
in under
tree
[音楽]
明日へば今度は単語のイメージも
が増と絶さあで体にインストールしていきますよ
うぉっ
はいありがとう movie
star
ついにしっ
アンダー
めねっ
はいらしい絵は今顔面をつぶって応答だけをインストールしていきますそうえっ
は積むべ
8分
iq フィニッシュ
in アンディ tree village 付
では今度はもう一度聞いてみてください
その fr 分スタート sen can you do
さぁさぁけるもう少しでもきゅるアッパー
ありがとうございまーす
はいということで日本人もう
単語も文法も学校で勉強しているからこの応答のイメージだけをインストールすれば
あなたはもうバイリンガルになれるんです
実は2年間日本中の中学校小学校などをめぐって5000人の方にこのバイリンガル
体験を提供してきました
受講生も入れると1万人の方が体験し71%が一発で7知恵聞けるようになっているん
です
ん
ということは文法も難しい単語も改めて benq する必要はありませんこの糸をと
イメージを持つだけであなたはすでにバイリンガルなんです
私には夢があります
世界に負けない文化世界に誇れる文化日本にはあるんです
例えば思いやりです
お財布を落として拾って持ち主に帰そうとする
この文化目が投資っていうと日本グレーなんですよね
でもパリとかニューヨークでももしそんな風な
文化ができたらもっと世界は思いやりをもって住みやすい社会になると思いませんか
だからもっと日本人がバイリンガルになって
自己表現していただきたいなと思っています
ですから日本は世界の思いやりタントその思いやり担当としてヘッドを使って即ペラを
とイメージ方で繰り返し繰り返し練習しもっともっと世界に思いやりを伝えていきませ
んか
以上です
[拍手]
[音楽]